Wonderful.
Okay. Sandra Clark, thank you
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm excellent. Thank you.
A little warm today, but otherwise great.
Definitely.
Definitely a little warm.
It's definitely some interesting times
that we're living in.
2020 continues to surprise us.
But over these next 20 minutes,
you are gonna help me
become a little bit more knowledgeable
about LinkedIn.
So, a professional platform
that most of the people
that are listening to this use.
It's something that I definitely enjoy
using all the time
not only because it helps me
connect with others,
but because I get exposed
to what other people are working on.
And one of the things
that is becoming more and more apparent
is that our social interaction
is no longer just,
the work-life balance is shifting,
and all of a sudden,
a lot of my personal connections
are also on LinkedIn.
And it's all becoming
one big container and mixture.
And I constantly am getting
both spam messages
and interesting messages
and I'm reaching out to people,
they're reaching out to me.
And the biggest question,
this question of building
the right resumes
have been going on forever.
Our LinkedIn is essentially
our new resume.
So, I'd love to spend these 20 minutes
talking about what I can do to maximize
on my appearance
and professionalism on LinkedIn.
But before that, Sandra,
I'd love to talk about
you learning how to swim.
Talk to me about that.
Okay. So, if I want to do something,
I just decide somehow I'm gonna do it.
So, somehow I managed to become an adult
without ever learning to swim.
My mother was afraid of water
so would never let me in the water.
And I got this wonderful idea,
I was living in Thailand,
that it'd great to scuba dive,
but you sort of need to swim
before you scuba dive.
- A little bit, yeah.
So it was a little awkward,
but I had a pool at the apartment complex
and I went in the pool.
And then I'd never put my face
under water voluntarily.
So, I filled the sink up
in the bathroom with water
and practiced putting my head in,
opening my eyes,
and teaching myself to swim.
Became a scuba diver.
Even became an instructor.
So it's kind of been the story of my life;
you want to do something,
figure out a way to do it.
So, I just want to paint the picture
that you're in the room
and you're filling up the sink with water
and you're putting your head down
so that you can get over the fear
of opening your eyes
and putting your head underwater.
Yes.
I just love it.
I've done stranger things.
Well if we have time in the end
I'll need to know one more strange thing.
But then, the fact that
you're not only scuba diving,
but you're becoming
a scuba diving instructor,
I think that's a real inspiration.
So that's just a wonderful story.
Sandra, how did you get started
with your expertise in LinkedIn?
What drew you to that?
Well, it's almost another
putting your head in the water story.
I was laid off
from the University of California
where I'd been for 25 years
and at that point thought I would stay.
They had other ideas.
They pushed me out the nest.
And who knew
but I discovered I could fly.
I started the whole job search thing
and going to these classes
to learn how to do a better resumé,
to do interviews, ... Linkedin.
And after the Linkedin training,
people would be coming up to me saying,
"Well could you just sit with me and help me?
You seem to get it,
and I'm really struggling."
So, after about 20 of these people
said, "You're really good at this. You should be charging"
So, in the heart of Silicon Valley,
... all an entrepreneur
I'm a little late to the game.
But I thought, why not?
So I started my own business
helping people set up LinkedIn.
So, helping people set up LinkedIn.
So everybody has almost, almost everybody,
especially in Silicon Valley,
has a LinkedIn account.
It's sort of our signature
like we said when we started out.
Why do people need help with LinkedIn?
I know why I need help with LinkedIn,
but I want to know more
about the general public
why they need help with LinkedIn.
Well you'd be surprised.
There are a lot of people
that don't have LinkedIn.
They've been at companies for so long,
they never needed to.
They just got recruited
from company to company.
They never needed to do that.
And then, all of a sudden,
they're walked out the door that day.
All of their contacts
are on their work email,
and they've got to start all over again.
So not everyone has one.
But also a lot of people just,
they threw it up there.
Maybe they just copied
everything on their resume and they go,
"Okay. Good, I'm done. It's there."
They're hugely uncomfortable about it.
What should be there?
What shouldn't be there?
What should I do?
And this whole social media
for the socially reluctant
is what I call it
making yourself comfortable,
putting yourself out there online.
So not everybody is comfortable
knowing how to do that.
And then once you've got it there,
what do you do with it?
How do you build relationships,
connections?
Who should you connect with?
Some people say,
"Oh, I only connect with people
I really know well."
Well I don't know about you,
but that would maybe be
30, 50 people for me.
"Oh well, maybe I'll connect with people
I've worked with."
Maybe that would be
another hundred or so.
So, you need to find a comfortable way
to grow your network
and then a way
to use LinkedIn appropriately.
So, there's a lot of work in that.
A lot of people want to be seen
as a thought leader
or a manager of choice,
because just like managers
are looking at your LinkedIn profile
to consider hiring you,
you're looking at them and saying,
"Hey, do I want to work for this idiot?
Am I gonna get to work
on cool projects?
What's his career path?
Oh same job, five years.
That means no opportunities for me."
So it works both ways,
and a lot of people
they don't necessarily want a new job,
they want to be recognized
for their expertise.
So I work with all of them,
and I have way too much fun.
I shouldn't even call it work.
I just love it.
So, give me a little bit more insight
into the actual work that you do.
Do you go on Zoom with them
and you walk them through
section by section?
Do you draw on previous experiences?
Are there certain patterns
that you're seeing come up again?
What are you noticing?
Okay. Well, I do work on Zoom.
I screen share.
I do like a mini tutorial and overview,
best practices, ins-and-outs, weirdnesses.
There are a lot
of weirdnesses on LinkedIn.
And then I hand over the control to them
and watch over the shoulder
directing them to make changes.
But also putting them
in control of their profile.
A lot of times LinkedIn do things for you.
They set up defaults,
and you don't even know what's happened.
You have people like they think
they've got their picture there,
don't realize that they've got it set
so no one can actually see their picture
unless they're connected.
Or they've got everything,
their public view completely closed,
so it makes it very hard to find them.
So, I teach them.
I'm a teacher at heart.
Once a teacher, always a teacher.
And then, so I teach them how to do it
and then I polish it up
a little bit with them.
Sometimes they're uncomfortable.
It feels like bragging about themselves.
So, I help them find wording
that feels authentic and appropriate.
And then how to use this;
the physical how to post things
so that you get noticed as well as the
what should you post.
Why is nobody looking at it
when you're just
pushing stuff out there
that you think is great
and nobody cares?
Well, you've got to engage them
in conversation
not just push it out at them.
So, teaching them how to do that
is part of what I do also.
So Sandra, I think
it would be wonderful to hear
a few specific ideas
of what my friends and I could do
as we listen to this podcast
or this interview.
We go back to our LinkedIn.
What are some of the common pitfalls
that you see people are making
that first and foremost,
we should be avoiding?
Okay. Well, one of the most obvious
is your headline.
Right under your name, this area
it's actually called your headline.
But the default in LinkedIn
is when you add a new job,
[crosstalk]
... title into your headline.
It's not called your job title,
but LinkedIn does that to you, or for you
depending on how you're feeling about it.
And so you are so much more
than engineer at XYZ corporation, owner at
You want your keywords
plus something about what you do,
what you deliver to the company
as an employee,
or what you deliver and offer
as a business owner.
So, headline is the most important thing.
When you comment
on other people's content in LinkedIn,
your name and your headline show.
So it's like a free advertisement.
So that's the number one thing,
and it's always be true,
but continues to be true.
The other thing I would say-
So just one second about the headline,
because one of the things
that my friends and I have been wondering
is that we enjoy taking part
in a lot of different activities
that we're very proud of.
We work at a certain company.
We volunteer at a certain organization.
We study at a certain school.
Now, and then it stems the question,
Yeah, we could write
a 50 character headline,
but at some point I'm sure that
there is a drawback
at having too much there.
Or trying to come across
as you're a little pushy.
Or that you're too much in marketing
and less in doing, right?
So, what is the balance
and how do you find that balance?
Oh, gosh.
That's the $50,000 question.
So, LinkedIn added the number
of characters you could have.
It used to be a 120 characters.
Mine is actually about 100
because I liked the way
it sat on two lines.
They've added now a 100 characters
so it's 220 characters
which is about four lines.
In general, I don't like headlines
that are that long.
If you give me too much to read,
I read nothing.
So, I would edit it down a bit.
A bit like with your advertising
on marketing grain,
what are the key things about you.
And there's an opportunity
in your about section to tell your story.
And that's where you can add in
some of this more interesting content.
But in the top, you want just enough
to identify your key skills,
maybe something
a little bit interesting about you
to make people want to connect.
What's different about you.
I mean if I see an invitation
to connect and it says,
"six figures in six weeks"
I know that he's gonna sell me
some automated product or ...
I don't even bother.
So that's obviously
too salesy, over the top.
You can talk about what you do.
I talk about
LinkedIn profiles for results
which hopefully describes what I do
but not being very pushy about it.
So you have to find that balance.
In general, I think
a couple of lines are enough.
Pick and choose what identifies you,
and then in your about section
tell me more.
Because the about section
has also changed.
It used to be,
we would go to your profile,
we would see the whole, used to be,
was it 1,500 characters.
I think it's grown to 2,000 now.
It's hard to keep track,
but do you really need that much.
And you used to see all of it,
and you could go there
and you could see someone's whole story
just by scanning it.
And that was great.
But we don't see that now.
We go to your profile.
We see the first three lines.
So, now you've got that
whole marketing advertising brain
you have to use again.
You've got to capture me
in those first three lines.
I don't know.
But you've been in Silicon Valley.
I don't reckon anybody
ever clicks on the see more.
So you've got to either have
your complete message
in the first three lines
and or be so intriguing
that we just got to open it
and read more about you.
So, how long does it take for you
to work with a person
to really understand who they are
and what special thing they have to offer
that would engage
with their other audience or other people
that they want to connect with?
Because it sounds to me
that a lot of this,
while there is the practical understanding
the character limit
and setting the settings correctly,
the real added value here
is understanding what,
in terms of marketing and messaging,
gets people to engage with your profile
and your posts, right?
Right. That's a great point.
And I use the expression,
"Walking is really just controlled falling"
The idea being you start to fall,
you put a foot there,
you catch yourself, you walk.
You start to fall, you pick your foot up.
So on social media,
especially for some of us
who are little more uncomfortable
about being online,
you've got to take a risk.
You've just got to be out there.
So, what I help people do
is be a little brave
and pick the words, for now,
this is not a lifetime commitment,
this is not marriage.
This is just pick what's true for now.
So, I will help people identify
what feels right for them right now
knowing that they're not
stuck with it, they can change it.
And just being a little bit brave
to do that.
And that's really hard for people.
So, sometimes if you go
for counseling or psychotherapy,
you go for months, years, whatever.
I work with people for two hours,
and we get it done.
And sometimes people will come back to me
for additional help,
but for the most part,
you know who you are right now.
Let's pick those words.
Try it out, throw it out there,
and walk on.
I'm not gonna let you do
anything embarrassing or wrong,
but it's okay.
Take a risk. Use a word.
I'm working with a lot
of executive coaches these days.
I'm taking an executive coaching program.
I've learned that that's probably
not the right thing for me
because coaching
you're supposed to just listen,
and want to help you get it done.
So, it may not be the right thing for me.
But I work a lot with them.
And there's a coach, he's so good
and he works on a particular kind
of harmonic leadership
which is rather unique.
Does everybody know what it is? No.
But maybe they're gonna be intrigued
and ask him.
So, be brave is kind of what I teach.
I think is my value add.
So then, the other sections
that we didn't get to touch upon,
which I believe is the experience,
the volunteer, the awards.
These sections are
on the bottom of the page.
I personally haven't spent much time
discussing the different organizations
that I volunteer my time for,
the different awards that I received,
mainly because in my perception,
most people are just
not gonna scroll that far down.
Maybe I have the wrong perception,
but talk to me about these other sections.
Are they important?
And if so, what is the right positioning
as we approach them?
Yeah. Well, some of it's
like finding conversation starters.
So when you go to someone's profile,
if you are both members
of a group or an association
under the highlight section,
which is right near the top,
it says that you're both members
of this group or association.
So right away
you've now got a conversation starter.
So, that's a really great way to use it.
If I do scroll down in your profile
and I see, oh, you volunteer your time
with the Boy Scouts of America
whatever it is, we've now, it's like,
Oh, my kid was in Boy Scouts.
You've got something to talk about.
So, we're constantly looking
for things you have in common.
My goal on LinkedIn
is never just to make a connection;
it's always to start a conversation,
a conversation that might lead
to a relationship.
And a relationship, if I'm lucky,
might lead to the privilege
of doing business with them.
For someone in my world,
my network is actually quite small.
I've got about 5,000 or so connections.
And that sounds a lot to some people,
but again, in my world, that's small.
But that's because
I don't want to just have numbers.
I actually want to have
real conversations with people.
And I do. I connected with
one of your former speakers
after watching her talk.
- Oh, wonderful.
I told her why I was connecting with her,
and now we started a conversation
about wine.
I love it. I just love it.
And is there an added benefit
in having more followers?
Because I see some people have
tens of thousands of followers.
Other people have 800.
What are the pros and cons
of having that very public appearance
of how many people you're connected with?
And a clarification,
which I need for myself, when it says
the number of followers on a page,
is that the number of connections
or just the number of people
that are interested in your profile?
It's a combination.
LinkedIn often uses
the language interchangeably.
Your connections are actually
the people you're directly
first degree connections with.
Your followers are people
who choose to follow you
because they want to see your content,
but you may not be connected with them.
So, I've got about the 5,000 connections
and maybe another thousand followers,
because I write content about LinkedIn
and people want to see that.
But in other places
it combines those two numbers.
So, if I look at your profile
and I see the number of followers,
that would be the combination.
In your case, probably most of them
are actually connections.
So the number, the magic number.
So there is some value, algorithmically,
is there even such a word,
in having over 500 connections. It makes it,
I just worked with somebody yesterday,
brand new user. He's been in an industry
where he wasn't allowed to be on LinkedIn.
So he literally started from scratch,
no connections.
And I tried to find examples
for him to look at,
and LinkedIn wouldn't let him
look at those examples
because his reach was not big enough.
So, of course, once he connected with me,
he's now only two degrees away
from my 5,000.
That just alone gives him more access.
So, let's say 500 at least
just to make it easy to find people.
In general, I say people should have
at least 30 connections
for every year of their age.
So I'll let you do your own math.
You're a young man, so that's easy.
I look at some people,
and I see the look of panic
in their eyes as they realize
what that number is.
And the reason I use that number
is because you meet 30 people
professionally a year, I'm sure.
Why would you not connect with them
on LinkedIn?
So, that's like a starting point.
If you're in business development,
you're gonna want
a bigger number than that.
If you want to be a thought leader
and get your content.
When you write content on LinkedIn,
you write a post, it actually goes out
to only maybe 10%
of all of your connections.
And they only see it in their newsfeed
if they happen to be looking
at that time.
So 10% of 5,000
is better than 10% better of 500.
Now, you can increase that number
from 10% to more like 25%,
that's about the max,
by engaging on LinkedIn,
the more you're active on LinkedIn.
And that would be the other big thing
I would tell people.
You need to be engaged on LinkedIn.
My name, Sandra Clark,
it's actually very common.
There's more than a thousand of me,
not ... look like me.
But, in general, if you put my name,
Sandra Clark, in the search bar,
I am gonna come up
as one of the top six
suggested Sandra Clarks in the world
because LinkedIn's algorithm says,
Hey, you're looking for a Sandra Clark,
really good chance you're looking
for this crazy lady
because she's active on LinkedIn.
And the guy who I was worked with yesterday,
who had no connections, did that,
and I came up first.
I love it. I just love it.
Sandra, 20 minutes go by fast
but I definitely learned a lot
and I have to go back and fix a few things
on my own LinkedIn.
Oh, I'll be looking.
Thank you very much for the insights
and for being so generous with your time.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you my favorite question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Okay. I overthought this a little,
but the obvious ones for me
are mentor and empathetic.
And after watching Mor Eini's interview,
I have to join her with white wine.
I love it. I just love it.
Thank you very, very much Sandra.
This is wonderful.
And stay safe and stay healthy
especially with all the fires
that are happening today.
Will do. Thank you so much.
A pleasure talking with you.
Wonderful. Bye bye.